[موسيقى]
في صناعة تبلغ قيمتها أكثر من 500
مليار دولار ، فإن أحدث لون أحمر شفاه
في صناعة التجميل ليس
أحمرًا تقليديًا ولكن أخضر ،
وهناك دفعة على مستوى الصناعة
لتحويل سلسلة القيمة بأكملها من
التعبئة والتغليف إلى المكونات الصديقة للبيئة
وسلوك المستهلك
الرائد  هذه التهمة هي واحدة من
أكبر الأسماء في مجال التجميل لوريال ،
إنها مثيرة للإعجاب للغاية ، القبة
رائعة حقًا ، التقينا بالرئيس التنفيذي
نيكولاس هيرونيموس في معرض دبي
لسماع ما تفعله شركته
لتصبح أكثر خضرة ،
لذا أخبرني عن كل ما تبذلونه من المثير
الابتكارات التي
ستعرضها في المعرض
جيدًا لدينا أه لدينا العديد
من الابتكارات من علاماتنا التجارية أه من
أكثر الأشياء التي أنا متحمس لها
أننا نعرض صالون
المستقبل
حيث سنكون أه نعرض الطرق  لجعل
تصفيف الشعر أكثر استدامة ،
نتشارك مع شركة Gyosa الناشئة التي
ابتكرت رأس دش يقلل من
استهلاك المياه بنسبة تصل إلى 65 في المائة ،
كما نقوم أيضًا بإعادة تدوير كل شيء  نانوغرام من
الصالون بالطبع الزجاجات والقمامة ولكن
الأهم من ذلك أن الشعر
يمكن إعادة تدويره وإنشاء شبكة
لامتصاص الزيت الذي تركته
في البحر ، لذا فهي حقًا
إمكانات لا تصدق
وهذا ما يعرضه لوريال
هنا  في معرض إكسبو ، صالون المستقبل
مع الصنابير التي توفر 60 مياهًا
للمنتجات التي تحتوي على مكونات تتطلب
كمية أقل من المياه لشطفها لإعادة التفكير في
النفايات والحفاظ على الطاقة ، لكن
صناعة التجميل في حالة تغيير هائل
إذا كانت ستصبح مستدامة حقًا ،
دعنا  كن واضحًا بشأن هذا ، نعم إنهم
يريدون فعل الخير ولكن هذا ليس من
نوع ما تعرفه عن إحساس عميق الجذور
بالإيثار ، أعني أن هذا موجود لأنك
تعلم أن الناس يريدون فعل الخير في ذلك
ولكن هذا أمر أساسي  العمل بشكل صحيح إذا
كنت تعمل في مجال السلع الاستهلاكية التي تواجه
نشاطًا تجاريًا ، فأنت تعلم من هو عميلك النهائي
جيدًا ، إنه حق الجمهور
، إنه المستهلك
هو من يشتريها ومواقف المستهلكين
تتغير.  أعلن عن
برنامج تمويل مستدام بقيمة تريليون دولار ، 500
مليار دولار منها في
مشاريع أه متعلقة بالمناخ
والنصف الآخر تريليون في
تمويل أكثر استدامة
[موسيقى]
ولا يتعلق الأمر
بالتمويل المستدام وجعل الشركات صديقة للبيئة
فحسب ، بل أيضًا جعل المصانع وراءها  هذه
الشركات الكبيرة أكثر صداقة للبيئة
منذ عام 2013 ، قمنا بتخفيض انبعاثات الكربون لدينا
بمقدار أه 81
مع زيادة إنتاجنا بمقدار
29 والآن لدينا التزام أه جديد
يسمى l'oreal للمستقبل حيث
نلتزم بالحصول على 100
من  المواقع سواء كانت صناعية أو
إدارية محايدة للكربون بحلول عام 2025.
لذا كم من الوقت قبل
أن تصبح مواقعك الصناعية محايدة للكربون ، ستقول
لأنك أيضًا متصل
بصناعات قذرة جدًا مثل صناعة البتروكيماويات
التي تعتمد عليها
للمواد الخام وبالطبع للتغليف
هذا أكثر من جانب المورد
وبالمناسبة ، فقد التزمنا أيضًا بالحصول على 95
بالمائة من مكوناتنا من
biosourc  المكونات الإلكترونية أو المتجددة ،
لذلك نحن نعمل مع شركائنا ، فهم
جزء
من تعهدنا فيما يتعلق بمواقعنا الصناعية
، والكثير منها محايد كربونيًا بالفعل ،
كما هو الحال على سبيل المثال في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، جميع
مصانعنا محايدة للكربون
بالنسبة لنا  هي حاليًا أكبر
سوق للجمال في العالم تليها الصين
واليابان ، بينما تتنوع توقعات النمو
، فمن المتوقع أن يتجاوز السوق 800
مليار دولار بحلول عام 2025
ولكن هناك شيء واحد واضح أن
الجمال الحريص موجود هنا ومثل العلامات التجارية
مثل l'oreal تواصل ذلك
سوف يتفاعل المستهلكون المبتكرون ، لكن الأمر سيستغرق
صناعة التجميل بأكملها
للانضمام لتصبح أكثر خضرة